well we are continuing our partnership
with Ted to highlight individuals and
ideas shaping our world in our series
ideas that matter this morning we are
taking a closer look at climate change
the latest government Climate Assessment
warns that by 2050 heavier rainfall in
the Midwest could prompt increase
flooding along major water waves like
the Mississippi River by 2071
temperatures in the southwest could
climb more than eight degrees leading to
longer droughts and at the end of the
century sea levels could rise by as much
as get the six feet in some places
endangering more than 130 million people
who live on the coast climate scientists
Katharine Hayhoe who co-authored the
report says warnings may not be enough
to spur action we don't need to be
talking about more science we've been
talking about the science for over 150
years the most important thing to do is
instead of starting up with your head
with all the data and facts in our head
to start from the heart to start by
talking about why it matters to us and
Katharine Hayhoe is here on set with us
good morning so happy to have you here
talking about such an important issue
you are a scientist yet you said when it
comes to dealing with climate change and
talking about it get out of your head
get into your heart and find shared
values why so often we think that we
have to be an environmentalist or a
liberal to care about a changing climate
but the reason why we care is because it
already affects each of us in the places
where we live
we only have to be a human living on
planet earth to care but why does it
have to become political I guess it's
the question that I'm asking and why is
this a debate at all it's gotten
political because of the solutions many
of us have been told that the only
solutions to climate change are to
destroy the economy and let the
government set our thermostat in reality
the solutions are very different they
involve getting our energy from clean
sources that don't pollute our air in
our water that grow the local economy
and that helped the u.s. lead in the
coming century so what you're saying
about the debate over solutions when you
hear people doubting the science is it
your view basically what they're really
doing is they're doubting the solutions
and they're just making it look like
they're doubting the science exactly
I've had thousands of conversations
and every single conversation I've had
including two just yesterday within 30
seconds pivoted from it's just a natural
cycle to the green new deals of
socialist plot talk about doubters you
had some in your own house your husband
I understand was a doubter how did you
convince it more have you convinced him
and what are those conversations like
well he was the very first conversation
that I had with somebody and irritated
by his position no I was surprised but I
knew he was a smart person I knew yeah
and so our conversation began with
mutual respect with me trying to figure
out well what do you think why do you
think that what are your reasons and him
doing this thing with me and so what did
you do what did you say to him
we had many conversations it wasn't just
a one-shot deal yeah we talked about the
data we went to NASA's website and
downloaded the data and he said you know
at this point I have to decide is it
warming or did NASA who put men on the
moon actually faked temperature data but
really what it came down to was talking
about constructive viable positive
solutions that help people rather than
hurt them how big of a setback in your
opinion was it for the president to pull
out of the Paris climate Accords well
interestingly cities states businesses
colleges tribes that represent over 40
percent of US emissions are still in the
Paris agreement so there still is
enormous forward action DFW Airport is
the first carbon-neutral
Airport in the country the city of
Dallas gets this energy already from
clean sources as do other towns in Texas
like Georgetown all around the country
we are seeing changes already happening
but we do need changes at the federal
level as well to keep up with what's
happening in cities and states so does
it well does addressing climate change
as we were talking about earlier need to
be an economy killer no it absolutely
doesn't I mean in Texas we have 30,000
jobs in wind and solar energy as well
already across the country there's more
jobs in the solar than in coal so we're
seeing these changes happen already but
unfortunately there are some winners and
some losers and the losers are the
corporations and the companies that make
their money off extracting processing
and selling fossil fuels you
devout Christian how does your faith
affect the way you look at the climate
question my faith is the reason why I am
a climate scientist I was studying
astrophysics as an undergraduate until I
just happened to take a course on
climate science to finish my degree and
I was absolutely blown away by the fact
that climate change is not just an
environmental issue like I thought at
the time it's a humanitarian issue it
disproportionately affects the poorest
and most vulnerable people here in the
US as well as around the world so I
thought to myself how can I believes
that we are to love others as we've been
loved ourselves by God how can I not do
everything I can to give people who do
not have a voice the voice they need to
help us fix this problem you said there
we could all do something to fight it so
just give us two top things that we can
all do you said you've even reduced your
own travel footprint what can we do two
things well the most important thing we
can do is what I talked about in the TED
talk talk about it and that's what we're
doing right here today that's one the
majority of the people in the country
don't talk about it if you don't talk
about it why would we care mm-hmm the
second thing we can do is step on a
carbon footprint scale if you're going
to lose weight the first thing you do is
step on the scale yeah if we're going to
lose carbon measure our carbon footprint
online there's lots of great resources
we can use to do that and figure out
what we can do personally that makes the
biggest difference so eat less meat put
your clothes on the clothesline haven't
seen one of those in gazillion years
yeah
reduce food waste and your light bulbs
all right I see tips like yours at
hotels yeah yeah all the time yeah I do
too
well I'm glad you brought some
enthusiasm to the table this morning for
this conversation and you seem a bit
optimistic about it too yeah thank you
thank you so much are you still married
I am okay see the ring I was wearing and
you know what he gave me for Christmas
what my panels Valentine's again all
right well thank you